hallo ich meine lieben freunde und
herzlich willkommen zurück zu einer
weiteren folge minecraft hero gestern
kam ja nur ein kleines passten video
bisschen gespielt habe auf einem papier
spendern also das war halt der fall
viele haben das nicht verstanden das war
halt also das kommt man auch nicht
verstehen dass man einfach nur so just
for fun weil ich keine zeit hatte einen
dachdecker anstatt jetzt einfach nichts
hochzuladen lade ich lieber seine kappe
ich weiß ist eine blöde begründung so
die stars aber egal ich hab's gemacht
von daher tut mir leid wenn euch das da
ein wenig verwirrt hat jetzt gibt's
natürlich weiter mit hero über die ich
auch noch mal ausprobieren wollte kann
ich das nicht eigentlich nur einmal
verwenden müssten die teams jetzt nicht
durchfallen in den nähten
naja jedenfalls ich bin ja letztes mal
ziemlich moment habe ich nicht hier
irgendwo hab ich dann hab ich nicht denn
ich hab doch ich muss doch hab ich denn
ich hab das habe ich nicht habe ich
nicht habe ich oder hab ich nicht mich
doch moment warte ich bin euch gleich in
meiner akte hiermit ein was ich jetzt
gerade fabriziere ich habe letzte mal
ein paar enten gesucht nicht gefunden
nicht so viele
und dann wurde ich halt getötet ich sehe
hier auch gerade gar nicht irgendwie wo
hab ich die dann habe ich hier in dem
rucksack oder habe ich ihm den rucksack
eigentlich müsste ich doch ich hab doch
hier das kann doch ich muss doch perfekt
an die das war ein rebell aber wir haben
hier bei nominum und wir haben teile wir
haben
steve jobs hut und seafood bekommen
verdammten heckel diamond die haben so
geile sachen bekommen eigentlich ne das
ist mega mega sexy gaal wir haben ja ich
habe glaube ich sogar noch mehr gefunden
doch irgendwo und zwar hab ich mir
gedacht ich nehme einfach mal wieder den
alten betrag nicht twitter hashtag dem
wir geben richtig halten twitter hashtag
den ich mit kinos schon hatte und zwar
konnte er irgendwie auch in den twitter
trends drin war des mikros und nehmen
davon einfach ein paar themen und
nebenbei wollte ich mir die rüstung
wenig verzaubern die hälfte der level
habe ich noch das eigentlich ganz gut
ein exot ist glaube ich immer noch in
der er müsste ich glaube es ist immer
noch in dieser verdammten dingsbums oder
ich sortiere nebenbei noch ein bisschen
so meine kiste
das kann ich auch machen das hier kann
ich erst mal eigentlich dass erst mal
alle sachen die ich hier von auf jeden
fall im müll schmeißen 14 türen gründung
von aluminium na dann mal gucken kann
ich nicht daraus
irgendwie geht das nicht ich mache ich
mir dann aus cotton ist das ein gar
nicht so oft die sachen schmeißt jetzt
einfach hinschmeißen weiß ich jedoch
hier einfach rollen jetzt wieder egal
und dann hab ich mir gedacht ich gucke
einfach mal bei twitter was treibt ihr
denn so unter den alten hashtag was
wollt ihr denn so von mir wissen und
dann kam da das thema was hältst du denn
da for a moment vincent lieber herr kong
kraft
wie findest du es das heutzutage schon
achtjährige ein handy oder ein tablet
haben
dazu ist meine story eingefallen die ich
letztens in meiner schule beobachten
konnte und zwar stand ich da so
friedlich in der pausenhalle nein okay
nicht friedlich habe schon alle
weggeboxt und dann auf einmal kam da so
ein kleines kind an in die schule und
meinte so kam dann mit einem kumpel an
oder so und dann so an ein watt ich habe
mein handy im auto vergessen oder waren
ich hätte mir nicht vors gesicht
schlagen können ich meine der war in der
fünften klasse würdig matip mit einer
fünften klasse ist man als meiner 15 19
ich glaube so 10 11 ist man da läuft er
da wirklich hin
nein ich habe mein handy vergessen ich
muss noch schnell meine mutter hier
irgendwie mit deinem handy dann anrufen
gibt der ihm sein samsung galaxy s3 und
was weiß ich dann war auf jeden fall
mega krass diese situation wir gucken
uns allen an bestehen darum gucken uns
an
dann schlagen uns wirklich so alle so
virtuell einfach gegen den kopf versetzt
nicht gemacht aber das war wirklich
einfach nur so mein gott g spielen mit
deinen freunden ihre pausen stadt weiß
nicht also ich kann das gar nicht
abwenden
ich habe ja auch manchmal in diesem
trakt unterricht für diesen ganzen
kleinen kinder der unterricht haben und
man läuft an ihnen vorbei und es ist
einfach so dass die alle mit ihren
handys darum sitzen und einfach
auf ihre handys gucken und nicht
miteinander unterhalten also die sagen
wir hier 4 0 heißt dies dass steve ach
so ich hatte sogar meine befristung mit
ich pizza bestimmt 1000 denkst du das
ganze befristung gefunden
genau das tief yve richtung bangkok
trotzdem war der kopf ist noch nicht
verteilt das eher cool welche kopf her
zurück verzaubern könnte und mir damit
quasi wie ein lexikon diamond machen
könnten als manager ich nehme einfach
die fresse raymond breu nicht an ninja
decke habe ich jetzt den nehme ich mir
auch mit zu euch ein terror den will ich
auch schon immer mal probieren das
probiere ich gleich auch denke ich
einfach mal ich packe erstmal die ganzen
sachen die ich erst mal ich brauche
pressetext
diese texte gar nicht hier einen kakadu
eis darf unnötig extra noch mal ändert
giants vor ort was ich sogar schon
besitzer wegschmeißen
ja ich muss ja auf jeden fall bald ein
bisschen aufräumen nicht nur so und zwar
bei gießen jetzt eine windrose anders
weil damals werden jedoch wo ist denn
hier der jockey möchte nicht abschießen
jeden die muss ich erst mal verzaubert
bevor ich den benutzer habe ich ihn
trotzdem benutzt also ich weiß nicht zu
diesem thema es ist halt einfach so es
ist derzeit alles im wandel also fast
alles im wandel es ist halt einfach so
dass leute die komplette vorstand hat
sich zurzeit einfach alles verändert
sage ich mal so von der kompletten
gesellschaft die gesellschaft verändert
sich das ist halt normal ist dass man in
so jungen jahren handy hat ist natürlich
klar das ist schön
das ist einfach so die neue generation
halten also die technik kinder
der ist ja auch schon die tatsache dass
ihr einfach jetzt sage ich mal 13 seite
und hier die videos cook das hatte ich
zum beispiel gar nicht so die
möglichkeit beziehungsweise da youtube
noch gar nicht so groß und da durfte ich
am tag nur eine stunde anpacken goldene
feder oder dadurch beispielsweise auch
nicht an den pc und alles mögliche das
war halt echt so ein bisschen
ja es war halt einfach anders aber dann
muss man sich damit zufrieden geben
obwohl ich an sich nicht nicht gut finde
eigentlich jetzt muss ich mich glaube
ich hier neben stellen und einfach immer
drauf drücken oder automatisch macht
aber jetzt kommt jemand aluminium rein
und dann brauche ich nur noch miniatur
herzen da kann ich ja schon mal die
opfer an machen weil ich ja jetzt auch
23 kann ich gar nicht gleich wieder zur
schule fahren muss ich könnte doch noch
ja eine kann ich ihnen noch aufnehmen
aber mehr auch nicht
so etwa trotzdem an richtig viele szenen
wo ich jetzt einfach mal so machen
könnte ich auch nebenbei ein bisschen
quatschen
es ist halt einfach so dass es zurzeit
sich alles verändert damit 20
zufriedengeben aber es ist halt so
unsere also es ist halt auch so dass
unsere oma und opa die sagen wir sind im
krieg aufgewachsen und sagen dann zu
meiner mutter und vater ja ihr könnt so
froh sein dass ich in frieden
aufgewachsen seit und so was alles und
deswegen sagen dann die eltern wieder zu
uns ja ihr seid ihr mit der ganzen
technik aufgewachsen ihr könnt hier von
danach fliegen und reisen das geht mega
schnell und wir werden eh ich werde
nachher innen in paar jährchen paar
jährchen also nicht zehn zwanzig jahren
wenn ich also irgendwie kinder habe
werde ich den auch sagen ja bei uns was
damals so wir sind zwar mit dem internet
aufgewachsen war bei euch ist es so ihr
fahrt auto und müsst euch einfach noch
einsetzen weil das magnetisch ist oder
irgendwie sowas oder ihr müsst euch
keine sorgen machen dass er morgens
kratzen müsst oder sowas meinem auto
weil es ist wahr es beheizte
frontscheibe gibt oder keine
ahnung was ich da noch alles verändern
wird oder die haben eine uhr um und
können sich die oder die ganze bildung
wir durch den chip eingesetzt und jeder
das gleiche land es gibt keine dummen
keine über klugen menschen
es gibt alle möglichen sachen oder das
nochmal die emanzipation besser wird und
so was alles es wird sich immer
irgendwas verbessern und verändern von
daher
es ist ein thema worüber man lange
diskutieren kann aber mittlerweile hat
sich so eingebürgert
was gefällt euch am meisten an hero also
ich sag jetzt mal euch weil die themen
hier eigentlich aus und mich gerichtet
waren ich nehme jetzt einfach nur den
hashtag weil ist gerade den 30 morgens
ist sich eine freistunde ab und ich
denke da kommen nicht so viele tolle
themen am meisten an hero gefällt mir
eigentlich das immer leute dass man
immer so die veränderung sieht also ich
bin zum beispiel offen server und seele
zum beispiel oder dass gebaut und auch
etwas gebaut das eigentlich ganz gut
ja ich werde beim neuen projekt
mitmachen lies dir gerne was über
schauspieler selbst wenn sie nur von
dreharbeiten sprechen
ach das ist von mentor von ventafonds in
dieser website die die ganze zeit bei
den twitter hashtag sie grad in den top
sachen sind weil das war ihm in den top
sachen die nicht kommentieren frage wenn
ihr wechseln könnte würdet ihr dann die
stadt wechseln ich finde eigentlich eine
schöne anstatt bloß relativ ruhig also
in stadt roth verändert sich ja immer
irgendwie was aber schön dass man es
eben ganz cool so diese kontinuität
welche zumindest die luft sprengen will
ich noch mal ganz kurz im abfall wieder
ausgestellt da drin ja schon heftigst
rutscht aber ganz schön heftig da drin
doch welches aus willich in luftigen
wasserlose online jetzt immer den ganzen
winter rhodos weg deswegen kann ich das
auch nicht so stark schießen
ich weiß nicht wer hier die luft
sprengen würde
also ich find meinen hass eigentlich
ganz cool bz wird ganz cool ich mag den
ganzen bogen die kaputten natürlich
nicht so gut wie fix ort irgendwo drin
pixelt wie sieht nach dem aus
das macht ihn echt fast gar kein schaden
so ein blödes diamond
das hat jetzt auch schon wieder alles so
heftigsten pfeile rein
ich schmeiße ich hallo augen der zweck
oder tiff hat irgendwie extra gemacht
damit wasser keine ahnung welches
ausführlichen luftsprünge also blöden
fragen eigentlich alle häusern in school
kennt ihr den elf ihren jungen der vom
auto überfahren worden ist redet doch
darüber
es werden so oft in letzter zeit ist
passieren so oft unfälle bei den kennt
ihr den 11 jährigen jungen ist nett für
eine frage wir kennen wie findet ihr den
halben jahr muss wissen wer der bar wo
es eher der hype ist ja schon lange
wieder webseiten halben jahr locker will
ich erstmal so gut sagen könnte da
hinkommen ja ich würde zahlen jetzt
schon lange wieder weg der halb jan hat
es halt immer ein highlight sind ja
eigentlich immer ganz cool wenn sofort
gehalt wird
ich finde das lied auch jetzt nicht
gerade schlecht also ich finds halt
es ist halt natürlich haftbefehl die
lyrische fi netz von e mails jetzt
natürlich nicht so vorhanden und in der
giants
erst mal ein bisschen kröten hier also
weiß nämlich 50 ganzen in ordnung also
ich finde jedes lied sollte immer so ein
hype haben und ich könnte jetzt auch dem
haft diene der macht ja irgendwie
überall mit zurzeit cash so kommr ein
aluminium ist noch was drin
eigentlich dann nicht okay gut ich habe
ohne scheiß 42 aluminium das ist so mega
krasner 52 aluminium
das ist echt heftig wie viel habe ich
von diesen komischen plättchen da ja
also zurzeit viel sich mein hero geht zu
ende wegen diesem weil er ein neues
projekt kommt deswegen möchte ich mich
auch so ein bisschen
ich sag mal engagieren den krieg angeht
so erstmal einen komischen ergo
ich mache mir gleich mehrere weil ich
weiß dass ich dir wieder verlieren werde
und jemand von euch auch hab ich hier
nicht irgendjemandem hängt also ich
denke auf jeden fall vor dem ende von
hierbei müsste ich eigentlich hier mit
fällig wäre mit dem ganzen haus ich
meine ich möchte eigentlich lieber nicht
das haus fertig bauen sondern
ich würde echt lieber nicht was machen
wir jetzt noch mal richtig aufrüsten
hier mit der rüstung und alles die
könnte ich auch gleich mal reparieren
gehen und dann halt noch ein bisschen
kämpfen
gebt mir fall ein wenn er ihn freunde
und ich brauche diese mini diese mini
herzen miniature herzen damit ich noch
mehr erleben bekomme und noch einmal
hallo items are golden girls meine damen
und herren
ok ich glaube dass mir zuerst mal
reichen um die ganze kette jetzt zu
reparieren
nicht dass jetzt ein fall von so einem
skelett kommt ich bin so tot
das wäre schrecklich so alles runter
variieren alles wieder drauf protection
anbrechen
so protection 1 an breaking runter das
parieren und action 3 an breaking 3
software schloss mit der kkr trennten
das am arsch ich weiß nicht lieber an
breaking manchmal lieber protection und
noch sollte sich bei der kann ich schon
mal anziehen
ich brauche meine damen und herren ich
brauche definitiv mehr level
so soll der pakt ein vergleich noch
drauf so hier noch am tag an breaking
so auf die beiden oberen muss sollte
darauf war schon wieder nach dir drin
herr luhukay doch eine böse aber bitte
lasst irgendwann ging's fallen
irgendwann miniatur herz jetzt ist alles
leer
christa bau verlassen manila immer noch
wie schnell sich regeneriert
lasst doch mal einen bildes miniatur
herzfehlern hat er ist ja immer noch was
lust mit dem sie stellen sich
regeneriert gucken auf die leben
hallo da 28 600 jetzt wieder bei 27 28
ich kann nur gucken wo seht ihr euch in
fünf jahren also habe ich ja schon mal
gesagt hoffentlich irgendwo am studieren
und ich weiß nicht ob ich dann noch
youtube machen wer den vier jahren das
kann ich jetzt wirklich noch nicht sagen
weil meine ganze zukunft sehe ich eher
offen und ich möchte mich das nicht so
festlegen dass ich sage ja in fünf
jahren sehe ich mich auf jeden fall hier
bei dem und dem unterallgäu youtube und
so wow
relativ er lässt einfach so diamond
sachen fallen die mal überhaupt nicht
wertvoll sünder ein gar nicht so einfach
in krems kiste kiosk es gehe hier rein
und der ganz rechts kaninchen müll
schmeißen
ich mache hier nach da hinten hin diesem
n tv
das ist so erbärmlich was sie machen wie
groß ist die hausarbeit meiner träume
fragen die mich so so die sehen so oder
wollen fragen dann frage ich die mal
irgendwie groß ist die hausarbeit meiner
träume watt laverty und christel
bräuchte ich hab ja ein
und wir müssen auch die folge beende
meine damen und herren ich habe ein ganz
klein bisschen wird geschafft und zwar
einfach ein bisschen levels gefertig
wetter noch die chance gleich ein
bisschen es sollte ja in der nächsten
folge auf die eher sachen drauf packen
obwohl ich schaffe es gar nicht mehr
noch eine folge aufzunehmen oder schafft
das ja ich glaube eine müsste noch gehen
doch ich glaube einen müsste noch gehen
wir sind beim nächsten mal wieder
belasten bewerten da wenn es euch
gefallen hat und sonst in der nächsten
folge werde ich mich dann heftig viel
erfahrungen sammeln meine sachen
verzauberte für die krieg und hoffe dass
ich miniatur als bekomme und dann wird
dann bald richtig jeder abgeschlachtet
auf dem server kommt egal wenn aus
meiner stadt ist das nicht das nicht das
ist nicht so gal schüsse